le chef du service de chirurgie
cardiaque du chr de metz vient d'être
suspendu son unité est déjà fermée
depuis le 11 octobre graves
irrégularités actes chirurgicaux non
validées ou encore pratiques illégales
le pré rapport de l' agence régionale de
santé est accablant il fait état d'un
taux de mortalité de 21 % cette année
c'est trois fois plus que la moyenne
nationale yvan macau anthologie subir
une opération du coeur dans cet hôpital
de metz serait beaucoup plus risqué que
n'importe où ailleurs il ya quinze jours
la découverte de ce taux de surmortalité
avait conduit les autorités de santé à
fermer immédiatement le secteur de
chirurgie cardiaque
aujourd'hui elles vont plus loin car la
suspension d'un chef de service est une
décision rarissime
le premier rapport d'expertisé publié
hier est accablant ces éléments
confirment la maintien d'une mortalité
très élevée
au global sur 2010 par rapport à 2009
avec une mortalité de l'ordre du double
par rapport à la moyenne nationale a une
particularité du triple jarre du
quadruplé à vis des interventions de
chirurgie des valves cardiaques
parmi les dysfonctionnements des actes
chirurgicaux qui ne correspondent à
aucune recommandation sanitaire des
opérations anormalement longue ou bien
encore un roulement très élevé des
médecins sans communication entre eux
mais le rapport pointe aussi de graves
irrégularités des comptes
l'an dernier les dépassements
d'honoraires aurait atteint ici plus de
320 milles euros
ce soir entouré d'une trentaine de ces
infirmières le chef de service mise à
pied dénoncent l'opacité selon lui de
cette enquête
je n'ai été entendu qu'une demi-heure
par la mission d'inspection pendant
laquelle je n'ai pas été en mesure
d'aborder précision des faits qu'il me
serait reproché se demande donc à
disposer d'une information loyale sont
ceux qui me reprochaient à moi même et à
mon service depuis la fermeture il ya
deux semaines les patients ont été
transférés dans deux autres hôpitaux de
la région
mais le service devrait reprendre ses
activités à metz dans les prochaines
semaines avec une toute nouvelle équipe
de praticiens